hey guys I'm Alanna or char Alanna Zod
and today you guys are watching my
review of the new Legend of Zelda game
on the 3ds a link between world which is
of course a sequel to a Link to the Past
if 500 years later counts as a sequel
pretty sure it does now I've got to say
I don't know if it's because this game
is particularly fast pace for a Zelda
game but I very very quickly fell in
love with it now when I say fast paced
I'm talking about the ability to go to
pretty much any dungeon you want to and
buy or rent items really really early on
in the game so dungeons are still
related to specific items but you can
actually buy most of these from a guy
who sort of rents out your house if you
rent an item and then you die you do
have to go back and get it again which
can be incredibly infuriating but it
makes sense or you can spend a very
small amount of time killing the
infinitely spawning enemy is cutting up
grass and pots and you can earn enough
money to actually buy items then of
course there's the story and I promise I
won't spoil anything here but I think
the new villain you guys probably my
favorite Zelda villain he basically has
an obsession with paintings and wants to
preserve people to keep them beautiful
on paintings he's also trying to unlock
the demon Ganon but I tried to ignore
that because I feel like a lot of Zelda
games just focus too much on Ganondorf
and it's a bit much Yoga is amazing on
his own he's witty he's charming and
he's incredibly creepy now I don't want
to spoil anything but of course I'm sure
most of you have seen in the trailers
that link does end up becoming a
painting himself however he has a
bracelet that can stop him from staying
like that and he can move around as a
painting but the idea that if link
didn't have that bracelet he would be
stuck on a wall is really really creepy
to me and definitely one of my favorite
things about the entire Legend of Zelda
franchise is that it looks so pretty and
bright and the music's gorgeous and
everything seems happy and childish but
there are really really dark undertones
the painting feature is actually pretty
amazing the fact that you can sort of
small for yourself onto a wall and then
view an environment entirely differently
and be able to search it out or find a
way over
in a way that you wouldn't have been
able to before is really really
appealing it sort of makes you think of
the game in three separate ways you've
got the huh I don't know how to get past
this this environment has some kind of
stone that I can't lift what do I do
then there's the painting aspect and
then there's the items aspect which is
general in all these other games one
major changes that this game definitely
doesn't hold your hand a lot of people
complained about Skyward Sword being too
easy or telling you what to do in this
game doesn't do that it marks a red X on
your map it doesn't tell you how to
actually get to that red X you could go
up the top of the map the side of them
at the bottom of the map approach from
all these different angles and try and
get there and they'll be obstacles in
your way and you don't know which way is
the definite way to cook I got a little
bit frustrated with that but not
actually because of the game just
because of me
sometimes I got pretty lost I'm really
bad at Zelda games actually perhaps my
only annoyance with the game is when
it's loading all you have to say walk
across the screen you're walking right
to left and then when you get to the
left there's a little breeze before it
loads the other side it doesn't just
follow a link in the center it has to
load different areas so yeah you'll walk
one side to the other and in the freeze
it is what gets me it's a noticeable
pause and I don't know for some reason
that really bothered me all in all it's
a really really beautiful addition to
the Legend of Zelda franchise and I
really hope we see more of yoga and more
of Laurel because it's all dark and
creepy and oh I made it snow Majora's
Mask that's terrifying
I would not have let me play in the
gorge mask as a kid but that's it for me
today you guys I'll see you next time